hello I'm John Cena doing my best Lance
Russell and welcome to wrestling support
[Music]
at sea-cocks
three four eight four interesting would
love to hit someone over the head with a
folding chair like they do in wrestling
matches how does this person always end
up being okay that's a fair question
here's the honest answer the people
aren't okay it is a steel folding chair
and you get hit with it it hurts like a
swarm of killer bees devouring your soul
it hurts and you think we get up and
we're okay we're not bruises breaks
tears we are trained professionals and
this is our job to actually do this I
don't know why anyone would want to do
it for recreation so leave that stuff to
us next at lives 93
I wonder if John Cena still owns this
costume I never owned that costume
I didn't own the wig I didn't own the
gold chain I didn't know the jacket it
was lovely
I wish I had because I would walk around
most of my days with this this is one of
the most attractive photos of me ever
taken whoever does own this costume if
you are in the business of renting it I
I have some money and I I may want to
may want to rent it for private or
public time franchise creatively spelled
with a pH 19 who currently is the best
wrestler in the world well we're in a
business of accomplishment and
championships of the height of that
accomplishment so right now I would say
a combination of Alexa bliss Charlotte
Flair Brock Lesnar and AJ Styles those
are our four top tier champions they are
the four best in the world at get to be
fit John Cena with exclamation point
what is a revenge
like I've never heard of it before I did
see it on the WWE website in the live
tour what's that
god bless so after a big event where you
have a very important match there are
winners and there are losers but we
never stop our we have our Super Bowl on
Sunday and we don't take an offseason we
have a television the next day so then
we go out on tour and call it a revenge
tour which if you were a loser in that
important match it's kind of like you
get another chance with not as many
people watching and headwall my roommate
and I drew you do you like it please
respond I do like it
the proportions are realistic the shape
of the skull and the attitude as a smile
on my face in both occasions that's also
realistic and it seems as if I have a
mason jar in my pants on one of them so
I frequently walk around with a mason
jar in my pants and they were very
realistic to that as well
and M Leigh Hearon why the dudes on
wrestling have no body hair it's so
weird
they are so shiny and smooth yeah it's a
turn-off to metrosexual well the laws of
attraction are different for everyone
technically there is a reason for no
body hair if you have long leg or arm
hair someone can grab it to picture
someone grabbing your hair which is why
I keep my six dollar fade the way it is
that hurts and if you're covered in
oil
people can't grab you which is why guys
tend to wear small outfits as well now
you can be as judgmental as you want but
when you're in the thick of it and
someone is trying to break you in half
you want to have every single advantage
you can I
advantage in 90s fashion and I don't use
oil but I do manscape from the eyebrows
down i wear jean shorts just because
people are scared by the very presence
of a grown man wearing something from
the 90s a velociraptor
how do WWE wrestlers even get hired and
they have to show up in costume give
their audition directly to Vinnie Mac
that would be Vince McMahon people have
different paths how was I hired I was
sought out by WWE recruiters I was
wrestling in small town flea markets and
outdoor barbecues in front of minimal
people and was seen and someone said hey
would you like a chance at wrestling in
front of larger crowds to which I said
absolutely but for different folks they
have different paths you have people
like Brock Lesnar and Ronda Rousey that
have been successful in other ventures
and have found their way to WWE so it's
different for everybody has there ever
been in an audition where people show up
in costume and talk directly to the
owner of the company absolutely
@ TJ hunter 90 what age is appropriate
to use your son to practice WWE moves
hash tag SRS if you have a son and you
are thinking of using him to practice
your WWE moves
I would suggest leaning more towards
counseling as a parent instead of asking
me that question
at f80 fries how do wrestlers come up
with their wrestling names for example
Seth Rollins you would think that that's
his real name but it's not my process
was very complex you see the name John
Cena is not my real name my name is dick
hammer Bush and it's a very difficult
government name to use because of the
connotation it provides so in thinking
of a fake name they thought of John Cena
simply eight characters two syllables
throw some trumpets behind it it just
works why don't I use dick hammer Bush
because that is just not who I am
I'm John Cena at blue MD what's it like
in a cage match it's like trying to
escape a cage or win a match at this
same
at TFC hooligans 69
I prefer DFC hooligans 68 oh you won
when one is training to become a
wrestler how beneficial would it be to
you as a wrestler to also study a
particular martial art I'm going to say
beneficial but not for the reason you're
thinking because studying a particular
martial art will also expand your
horizons you also get a good awareness
about how the body moves and the
principles of basic martial arts it kind
of gave you stuff you can take with you
outside of the mat so yes all good but
for reasons different than you may see
at the highwayman 84 under which one he
likes at set mace what is it like to
work with Vince McMahon what is he like
as a person he is unbelievable it's
fantastic to work for Vince McMahon
because he demands the best of everyone
who he works with and I say with because
you were treated like a part of the
family and he demands the best and
that's one thing but he gives you his
absolute best every single day and
that's another it's been an honor to sit
under his learning tree for almost two
decades
at UT T Rob what is the most dangerous
move in wrestling with this emoji next
to it they're all dangerous I think the
most impactful one ever designed is a
move that I've created that I did not
think would catch on we're simply where
you wave your hand in front of your face
and say you can't see me now I know out
there the wrestling purists are going to
pull their hair out but think of this my
friends has there ever been another
performer to wave his hand in front of
his face and be given an actual
superpower think think to yourself how
many times you've seen on your precious
internet pictures of myself another
human being and you write comments of
like but there's no one over your
shoulder Rob how did you take a picture
with John Cena this has made me
invisible
top that
so interweb I always love chatting
wrestling WWE and sports entertainment
with you
so I'm John Cena and thank you for
watching wrestling support